FORMER ACTING WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
OF STAFF, MICK MULVANEY.
HE LATER SERVED AS SPECIAL ENVOY
TO NORTHERN IRELAND BUT RESIGNED
FROM THE POST FOLLOWING THE
CAPITOL ATTACK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US THIS MORNING.
YOU'VE SEEN THE NEWS OVERNIGHT.
THE HOMELAND SECURITY INSPECTOR
GENERAL PUT OUT THIS STATEMENT,
SAYING THAT TEXT MESSAGES FROM
JANUARY 5th AND 6th WERE
DESTROYED AFTER THE IG ASKED FOR
THEM.
HOW DOES THAT LOOK TO YOU?
>> MORNING, JOHN.
IT DOESN'T LOOK VERY GOOD, BUT
WHEN YOU SORT OF DEEP -- DIG A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO IT, IT
BECOMES EVEN MURKIER.
THE SECRET SERVICE, I THINK, PUT
OUT A STATEMENT SAYING THAT NONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THE COMMITTEE
WAS INTERESTED IN WERE
DESTROYED, ALSO SAID IT WAS PART
OF AN ORDINARY TRANSITION FROM
OLD PHONES TO NEW PHONES, AND
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
ACTUALLY THE GUY THAT WAS
APPOINTED BY TRUMP, AND THE
PERSON RUNNING THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WAS UNDER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
SO, IT'S VERY CONFUSING.
IT MAY WELL BE THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE THAT'S COMPLETELY
NORMAL, IT MAY BE SOMETHING
ELSE, BUT I THINK IT'S PROBABLY
TOO EARLY TO JUMP TO
CONCLUSIONS.
IT IS YET JUST ANOTHER
HEAD-SCRATCHING MOMENT REGARDING
JANUARY 6th, HOWEVER.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH WE DON'T
KNOW HERE, BUT IT IS INTERESTING
THAT IT WAS A TRUMP-APPOINTED
INSPECTOR GENERAL MAKING THIS
REQUEST AND INFORMING PEOPLE
THAT THESE PIECES OF INFORMATION
WERE DESTROYED AFTER THE
REQUEST.
WHY WOULD THE SECRET SERVICE BE
UNCOMFORTABLE?
WE'VE SEEN IT IN OTHER EXAMPLES
TOO, WITH FULL DISCLOSURE OR
FULL DISCUSSIONS WITH WHAT
HAPPENED OR THEIR ROLE ON
JANUARY 6th?
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
KEEP IN MIND, AS SOON AS CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TESTIFIED, THE U.S.
SECRET SERVICE WAS VERY QUICK TO
SAY THEY WOULD BE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY UNDER OATH THAT WOULD
COUNTER SOME OF THE ALLEGATIONS
THAT SHE MADE.
THEY'VE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THEY'VE BEEN COOPERATING WITH
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING.
I'VE NOT HEARD ANYTHING
DIFFERENT UP UNTIL NOW, I GUESS,
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SUGGESTING THAT THE U.S. SECRET
SERVICE HAS BEEN ANYTHING BUT
FULLY FORTHCOMING.
YEAH, THEY'VE GOT SECRET IN
THEIR NAME, BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, AND I HAVE WORKED
WITH THEM FOR FOUR YEARS, I HAD
A SECRET SERVICE DETAIL FOR
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF, SOME OF
THE MOST HONORABLE AND UPRIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND SORT OF BEING ATTRACTED TO
THIS AGENCY.
SO, I'M WILLING TO GIVE THEM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT AT THIS
POINT.
THEY SAID THEY TESTIFIED TO
CONGRESS TWICE UNDER OATH THAT
WHAT THE -- PART OF WHAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WAS SAYING WAS
NOT ENTIRELY ACCURATE, SO AGAIN,
TOO EARLY TO JUMP TO
CONCLUSIONS.
I'M INCLINED TO BELIEVE THE
SECRET SERVICE ON THIS ONE, BUT
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS AS THE
COMMITTEE DIGS A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER.
>> IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
ALSO, IN THE LAST FEW HOURS OR
12 HOURS OR SO, CNN HAS HEARD
THAT A D.C. METRO POLICE OFFICER
CORROBORATED THE VERSION OF
EVENTS DESCRIBED BY CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, THAT SHE HEARD TOOK
PLACE ON THE MORNING OF JANUARY
6th WHERE DONALD TRUMP WAS IN
THE LIMOUSINE TRYING TO GO TO
THE CAPITOL, A D.C. METRO POLICE
OFFICER CORROBORATED THE VERSION
OF EVENTS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE SPECIFIC
DETAILS ABOUT LUNGING FOR THE
WHEEL OR CHOKING, BUT WHAT'S THE
IMPORTANT TAKEAWAY FROM THAT
EVENT, FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WANTING TO GO TO THE CAPITOL?
>> YEAH, IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION, AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
CASSIDY SAID SHE HEARD THIS FROM
SOMEONE ELSE WHO HEARD IT FROM
SOMEONE ELSE.
IT WAS SECONDHAND HEARSAY.
I DON'T CARE IF THE PRESIDENT
LUNGED AT THE WHEEL OR ASSAULTED
A SECRET SERVICE AGENT, ALTHOUGH
THE LATTER IS A CRIME, BUT THE
REAL ISSUE IS, WHAT WAS HIS
REACTION WHEN HE WAS TOLD THAT
HE COULDN'T GO TO THE CAPITOL?
WLO
WHETHER OR NOT HE GRABBED THE
WHEEL OR GRABBED A PERSON, WAS
HE REALLY, REALLY ANGRY?
DID HE FLY INTO A RAGE?
I THINK THERE COULD BE EVIDENCE
COMING OUT TO THAT EFFECT.
THAT TO ME IS MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT, HIS EMOTIONAL
REACTION, HIS IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
TO NOT BEING ALLOWED TO GO DOWN
TO THE CAPITOL ON THAT DAY, TO
MY MIND, SPEAKS A LOT MORE TO
HIS STATE OF MIND THAN WHETHER
OR NOT HE ACTUALLY GRABBED THE
WHEEL OR GRABBED HIS SECRET
SERVICE AGENT.
>> AND THE FACT THAT HE WANTED
TO BE AT THE CAPITOL.
TO DO WHAT, DO YOU THINK?
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS WHOLE THING
IS BECOMING ABOUT.
I TRIED TO FIGURE OUT WHEN THESE
HEARINGS STARTED, WHAT THE PLAN
WAS, AND I THINK I SEE A THEME
NOW WHICH IS THAT EVERYBODY SORT
OF ACKNOWLEDGES THAT WHAT THE
PROUD BOYS DID AND WHAT THE OATH
KEEPERS DID WAS A CRIME.
AND WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE THE
COMMITTEE IS TRYING TO DO IS
DRAW A LINE BETWEEN WHAT THOSE
GROUPS DID THAT IS CRIMINAL AND
THE WHITE HOUSE OR EVEN THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
AND IF THE PRESIDENT WAS IN THE
SECRET SERVICE, WAS IN THE
LIMOUSINE AND REALLY, REALLY
WANTED TO GO DOWN TO LEAD THIS
EFFORT, IT MIGHT LEAD TO MORE
EVIDENCE THAT HE WAS INVOLVED
WITH SOME OF THE PLANNING FOR
IT.
PERSONALLY, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DOES.
HE'S NOT A LONG-TERM PLANNER,
BUT IT WILL BE CURIOUS TO SEE IF
MR. BANNON TESTIFIES AND M
MR. NAVARRO TESTIFIES AND
MR. MEADOWS TESTIFIES AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
COMMUNICATION DIRECTLY BETWEEN
THE RIGHT-WING EXTREMIST GROUPS
AND THE TRUMP INNER CIRCLE.
>> HAVE THEY RAISED ENOUGH
QUESTIONS?
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING VERY
CAREFULLY AND YOU'VE WRITTEN
ABOUT WATCHING THEM AND YOU
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
WATCH THEM, INCLUDING
REPUBLICANS.
HAVE ENOUGH QUESTIONS BEEN
RAISED, DO YOU THINK, IN PUBLIC,
THAT YOU THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SHOULD BE INVESTIGATING?
>> WELL, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DOESN'T -- SHOULD THEY
INVESTIGATE?
YES.
THE QUESTION I USUALLY GET IS,
SHOULD THEY BRING CHARGES?
IT'S WAY TOO EARLY TO JUMP TO
THAT CONCLUSION.
KEEP IN MIND, MUCH OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT'S BEING PRESENTED
AT THE HEARING WOULD NEVER BE
ALLOWED IN COURT.
MIGHT BE ALLOWED IN A GRAND
JURY, BUT HEARSAY EVIDENCE WOULD
NEVER BE ALLOWED IN COURT AND
THE DOJ IS MUCH MORE SERIOUS.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO CHARGE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OR THIS INNER CIRCLE, THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE IT VERY,
VERY SERIOUSLY.
THE POLITICAL INVESTIGATION
THAT'S GOING ON NOW IS AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT LEVEL SO I
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TAKE IT WITH
A GRAIN OF SALT, WHAT THEY'RE
SEEING COMING OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT CERTAINLY, I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
I DEFENDED THE PRESIDENT FOR
ALMOST A YEAR, SAYING THAT I
REALLY DID BELIEVE THAT THE
SPEECH DIDN'T LEAD TO THE RIOT,
THAT IT WAS ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
AD LIB THINGS THAT DONALD TRUMP
DID THAT SORT OF GOT OUT OF HAND
AND HE WASN'T INVOLVED IN ANY
PLANNING AT ALL.
I THINK CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TESTIMONY, ESPECIALLY, THAT THE
PRESIDENT KNEW THERE WERE GUNS
WITH THE PROTESTERS, AND THAT
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN DIRECT
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
INSIDE OF THE OVAL -- EXCUSE ME,
THE WEST WING AND THOSE
RIGHT-WING GROUPS SORT OF CAUSED
ME TO STEP BACK AND SAY, OKAY,
WAIT A SECOND, LET'S FIND MORE
OUT ABOUT THIS AND THAT'S WHERE
I AM.
AND I THINK A LOT OF FOLKS,
INCLUDING MANY REPUBLICANS, ARE
IN THE SAME BOAT.
>> ALSO, THE INSINUATIONS ABOUT
POSSIBLE WITNESS TAMPERING.
I KNOW YOU THINK THESE ARE
IMPORTANT.
CNN HAS REPORTED THAT THE PHONE
CALL THAT DONALD TRUMP PLACED
WAS TO A WHITE HOUSE SUPPORT
STAFF MEMBER WHO DOES NOT
NORMALLY HEAR FROM DONALD TRUMP.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT?
>> YEAH, THAT ONE GOT MY --
SCRATCHING MY HEAD A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE I SORT OF KNOW THE
PEOPLE IN THAT UNIVERSE, AT
LEAST, I DID WHEN I WORKED IN
THE WEST WING, AND THESE WOULD
BE FOLKS LIKE THE STEWARDS AND
SUPPOSEDLY IT WAS RELATED TO
SOME OF CASSIDY HUTCHINSON'S
TESTIMONY.
ONE OF THE THINGS SHE SAID THAT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN THE
BACK HALLWAYS OF THE WEST WING
WHERE THE INCIDENT ABOUT THE
THROWING OF PLATES OR THE
THROWING OF LUNCH OR THE PULLING
OF THE TABLE CLOTH OFF THE
TABLE, THE STEWARDS WOULD SEE
THAT.
THE STEWARDS ARE NOT TYPICALLY
IN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, CNN IS
ALSO REPORTING THAT THE PERSON
WHO GOT THE PHONE CALL FROM THE
PRESIDENT WAS SO ALERTED TO IT
THAT THEY CALLED HIS OR HER
LAWYER.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE STEWARDS
WOULD HAVE A LAWYER.
SO, I'M NOT SURE WHO THE
UNIVERSE OF PEOPLE WOULD BE IN
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE, I'D BE
CURIOUS TO SEE IF THE COMMITTEE
DOES ACTUALLY HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
I ASSUME THEY DID OR ELSE IT
WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE FOR LIZ
CHENEY TO MENTION IT.
BUT IT'S JUST ANOTHER THING THAT
WE NEED TO WAIT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS BEFORE WE JUMP TO ANY
CONCLUSIONS.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP WAS INTERVIEWED AND
HE SAID AT THIS POINT, IT'S NOT
A MATTER SO MUCH OF THE HE RUNS
FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN, BUT AS HE
PUTS IT, I WOULD SAY, MY BIG
DECISION WILL BE WHETHER I GO
BEFORE OR AFTER, SEEMINGLY TO
REFER TO THE MIDTERMS, DO I GO
BEFORE OR AFTER?
THAT'S MY BIG DECISION.
WHAT HAPPENS IF HE GOES BEFORE
THE MIDTERMS?
>> THE MIDTERMS BECOME ABOUT
HIM, BY THE WAY, AT LEAST A
LITTLE BIT.
ALL POLITICS IS STILL LOCAL, AND
IF YOU'RE STILL WORRIED ABOUT
PAYING $5 FOR GAS IN RURAL
ILLINOIS, THAT'S GOING TO DRIVE
YOUR DECISION MAKING A LOT MORE
THAN WHETHER OR NOT PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS ALREADY ANNOUNCED TO
RUN IN 2024.
SO, I DON'T PUT THAT MUCH SORT
OF WEIGHT ON THE PRESIDENT'S
IMPACT ON THE MIDTERMS.
BUT IT COULD CERTAINLY HAVE SOME
IMPACT IN SOME DISTRICTS.
I THINK THE REAL IRONY HERE,
JOHN, IS THAT IF PART OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PURPOSE WAS TO
DAMAGE DONALD TRUMP TO WHERE HE
WOULDN'T RUN OR WOULD DISCOURAGE
HIM FROM RUNNING, IT'S ACTUALLY
HAVING THE EXACT OPPOSITE
IMPACT.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO BE
ABLE TO TELL HIS SIDE OF THE
STORY.
HE FEELS LIKE HE'S NOT BEING
REPRESENTED AT THE COMMITTEE,
AND THAT HE WILL CHOOSE TO GET
THAT HIGHER -- THAT LARGER
PODIUM, THAT LARGER PLATFORM AS
A CANDIDATE AND ANNOUNCE EARLIER
RATHER THAN LATER.
>> YOU TOLD MY FRIEND, CASEY
HUNT, THAT YOU WOULD SUPPORT A
LOT OF PEOPLE BEFORE YOU
SUPPORTED DONALD TRUMP FOR THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION.
DO YOU HOPE HE DOESN'T RUN?
>> YEAH, I DO.
I JUST THINK IT'S BETTER FOR THE
PARTY.
I LOOK AROUND, AND I LOOK AT
FOLKS LIKE RON DeSANTIS AND MIKE
PENCE, MIKE POMPEO, GO DOWN THE
LIST, TIM SCOTT, NIKKI HALEY,
THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS THAT THE
REPUBLICANS CAN VOTE FOR THAT
GET THE SAME POLICIES AND THE
SAME SORT OF WILLINGNESS TO
STAND UP AND FIGHT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAD WITHOUT THE BAGGAGE, AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IT'S IMPORTANT IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S IMPORTANT IN THE SENATE.
I THINK YOU GET A LOT OF THE
BENEFITS WITHOUT A LOT OF THE
DRAWBACKS, SO, YEAH, I THINK
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS ARE AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THESE HEARINGS.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK YOU, YOUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, JOHN BOLTON, WHO WAS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR WHEN
YOU WERE THE ACTING CHIEF OF
STAFF, HE WAS SPEAKING TO JAKE
TAPPER THE OTHER DAY AND HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT, HE DIDN'T LIKE
THE FORMULATION THAT SOME PEOPLE
USE THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
ATTEMPTING A COUP ON JANUARY
6th.
AND THIS WAS THE EXCHANGE THAT
HE HAD WITH JAKE.
LISTEN.
>> ONE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
BRILLIANT TO ATTEMPT A COUP.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THAT, AS
SOMEBODY WHO HAS HELPED PLAN
COUPS D'ETAT.
NOT HERE, BUT OTHER PLACES.
IT TAKES A LOT OF WORK.
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT HE DID.
IT WAS JUST STUMBLING AROUND
FROM ONE IDEA TO ANOTHER.
ULTIMATELY, HE DID UNLEASH THE
RIOTERS AT THE CAPITOL.
AS TO THAT, THERE'S NO DOUBT.
BUT NOT TO OVERTHROW THE
CONSTITUTION, TO BUY MORE TIME
TO THROW THE MATTER BACK TO THE
STATES TO TRY AND REDO THE
ISSUE.
>> RAISED A WHOLE LOT OF
EYEBROWS, AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
HELPED PLAN COUPS D'ETAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT PIECES
OF THAT.
LET'S DEAL WITH THE PRESIDENT
FIRST.
I THINK JOHN'S PROBABLY RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT A CHESS
PLAYER.
HE'S NOT MOVING PIECES ACROSS A
CHESS BOARD IN A GRAND PLAN TO
OVERTHROW THE GOVERNMENT.
I THINK JOHN'S TAKE THERE COULD
BE ACCURATE, IN THE PRESIDENT
WAS DOING SOMETHING THAT COULD
STILL BE ILLEGAL, BY THE WAY, TO
BUY TIME.
THAT STRIKES ME AS SOMEWHAT
ACCURATE.
ON THE PART ABOUT JOHN BOLTON
PLANNING COUPS, DOESN'T SURPRISE
ME THAT JOHN IS PUMPING HIMSELF
UP, BUT I DON'T PUT MUCH WEIGHT
IN HIS VERSION OF HIS PLANNING